can I ask you a question about the
Catholic church and the
papacy not here huh yes you can because
uh the the anti-tr is not showing up I
goad ask me if I can answer yeah I've
been been wrestling with a couple of
demons lately and one of them actually
um kind of frustrated me a fair bit
actually um claims that the Catholic
Church actually started Islam um back in
the day is there any truth to that at
all I haven't been able to find any yeah
no it's a lie from the P let me give you
a little history I'll give video watch
boy this teach okay yeah there's that
one as well as that all the church um
the Catholic Church collects basically
aizia from all of the other
denominations as well out there let me
share share with
you a theory that was started by Chick
Publications I'm talking to everyone I
was raised on a diet of chick tracks
chick Chi CK
tracks Jack T chick became
Popular by producing little cartoon
tracks of the Gospel message but he was
very anti-catholic so he did a lot of
tracks talking about Catholicism steeped
in mystery religious cults it's
egyptology you know comes from Nimrod
samaris and it's it's Pagan goddess
worship well he had someone who claimed
to have been a Jesuit his name name was
Alberto Riviera now I grew up on this I
used to eat the tracks and eat these
books this is why I was paranoid about
the Catholic
church I was paranoid because I just had
come back to the Christian faith I'm
reading chick tracks I'm reading their
magazines they have like comic books
it's all like comic books I'm reading
the the information by Alberto Riviera
who claimed he was a Jesuit spy sent INF
Protestant churches to destroy them from
within but that he got saved
okay now according to him his
uh his
Jesuit boss told him that Islam was
started by the Catholic church because
Muhammad's first wife I want you to hear
it that's what yep doesn't match up I
want everyone to hear this okay and I'm
G to show you the comic it's actually
you go to Chick it's there the comic
book it's called The Prophet I read the
comic they made a comic book he said
that uh
Muhammad's first wife was actually a
Catholic nun so the pope gave her orders
go to Arabia find a man that you can
control and tame so he can be my
right-hand man in Arabia to subjugate
Arabia and all the heretical Christian
groups to the rule of
Rome so she I'm sorry this you went this
is exactly what I was exactly what I was
hearing yes so so she went to ro uh
Arabia she found Muhammad but Muhammad
became too big for his britches he
became uncontrollable because he's a
narcissist and he turned against the
Catholic
Church y this is I looked at I went
through the um timelines because I think
she died in was it 610 or 69 or
something yes he uh no Muhammad became a
so-called prophet in 610 she died about
before Muhammad migrated to Medina so
she would have died around 623 so about
620 620 ad but the problem is this is a
Lie from the pit ofel there's not a
shred of historical archaological
textual evidence the earliest evidence
from a Christian perspective on Islam
this is it by the way chick publication
this is what I'm talking about I'll show
you the comic book that's this based on
it's called The Prophet yeah Prophet now
the earliest evidence we have on Islam
comes
from John of Damascus here it is this is
it guys this is the comic book this is
it this is writer this is the story The
Prophet so it comes from hold on I
didn't show it to you guys sorry about
that because right here this is it here
right here this is the comic book this
is it folks this is what it's this is is
all based on John of Damascus is writing
in the 700s about 100 years after
Muhammad supposedly lived right he's
writing in Syria he's a Christian he's
considered a church father he's one of
the greatest saints that ever lived he's
discussing Islam you know what he says
Islam
is you know what he says it is no he
says Islam is actually aryanism I'm
going to explain what aryanism is okay
arianism not neo-nazism Neo no no the
term aryanism I'm going to put on the
screen this is it by the way guys this
is the garbage can that chick produces
okay the term aryanism put it on the
screen
aryanism aryanism right here on the
screen you're gonna see it means those
who believe like Aras well who the hell
is Aras well I'm going to give little
aryanism Aryans arianism belief of Aras
Aryan who follow Aries okay well who the
hell is Aries around 318 ad 318 ad there
was a priest named Aras in Alexander
Egypt an African who was influenced by
Greek
philosophy and so because of the
influence of Greek philosophy he
concluded that Jesus Christ in his pran
existence Jesus Christ in his pran
existence was created by God the Father
so God the Father Was Alone God the
father was
alone and then he created the logos the
word his son who then became flesh so
anyone who teaches that Jesus is the
first creature of God is aryanism is an
Aran so Joe's Witnesses are modern arens
meaning Joe's WT S as well yep seven day
well yeah that's exact adventism does
believe that historically so anyone who
teaches that the father created the son
first that's arenis that means they
believe like Aries now he was condemned
because the scripture does not teach
that but John of Damascus said that
Muhammad was trained by an Aryan priest
so someone who believed like Aras taught
Muhammad aryanism so according to the
earliest sources Muhammad was not
trained by Catholics he was trained by a
priest who believed like Aras Christ was
the first creature of the father a
heretic priest yes and you know what
ironic we even have Muslim sources where
Muhammad now again we don't know if this
comes from Muhammad because remember the
Islamic tradition were written over 100
years after Muhammad supposedly lived
that's why you have historians who say
it's highly doubtful that maybe there
was historical Muhammad and if he
existed he wasn't Muhammad of later
tradition but when you go to the Islamic
sources the Islamic sources say that
Muhammad supposedly wrote a letter to
the
Byzantium Emperor the emperor of the
Byzantine Empire because at that time
Rome the official religion of Rome is
Christianity bz Byzantium Christianity
or Byzantine Christianity that's the
Christianity of the Eastern Orthodox and
the Catholic churches because they were
one and this is called Byzantine
Christianity then they split in 10 54
anyway the emperor of the Byzantine
Empire his name was
hercus now according to the Muslim
sources Muhammad supposedly sent a
letter to hercus and he told him to
submit to Islam and then he warned him
if you don't then know know that you
will be punished for the sin of the Adin
here it is AD here's the
article he will be punished for the sin
of the ad now I'm give it to you in
private chat okay now right here and for
the rest of youin is Arabic for the
followers of Aras meaning Muhammad
according to this Source found himself
or thought of himself as the champion
and defender of
aryanism he thought he was defend
arianism against the trinitarian
Christians because hercus was a
trinitarian and so according right here
here's the word you you herac
will be found guilty of the sin of
thein is Arabic for Aryans those who
follow
Aras it's right there yeah you see that
so that means John of Damascus was right
John of Damascus says Islam is an
Aryan heresy it is a sect of arianism
because John of Damascus did not
consider Islam a separate religion he
considered it a Christian cult a
Christian heretical sect that believe
like areas and here we have Muslim
sources saying it
see here it is I gave you the the the
link and then there are Muslims who
admit I quote Muslims saying yes this
word most likely means the followers of
Aras so Muhammad thought of himself as
the champion and defender of
Aryans he thought of himself in a lot of
ways didn't he yeah so this non garbage
that
supposedly
supposedly the Catholic Church sent a
nun Khadijah to try to tame him now
that's garbage man don't believe the
garbage yeah now look I must admit it it
Disturbed me a bit not enough to
actually leave the Catholic Church it um
pardon the pun it pissed me right off
because on one hand I kind of thought
well it could be plausible um from the
way it was delivered to me and that and
then like as you've been saying the last
few days there's wolves everywhere um
right throughout it s brother notice
everyone and his mother attacks the
Catholic
Church yeah and this this is what I
couldn't get through to this guy as well
that if you actually remov the Catholic
church out of the equation he wouldn't
have a Bible he wouldn't have anything
at all to actually refute or to talk
about but still couldn't accept that
even the recent week the pope made it
very difficult for Catholics to
Catholics to be excited about their
Catholicism because these statements
everyone in their grandmother is now
doing streams oh my goodness if you see
the videos that are popping up and so
now you have Catholics who are who are
being crushed because they're like what
do we do you remain end till the end
brother it's all you can do and the the
um correct translation to the
vicarious I can't remember it but what's
written on the Pope's hat is actually
representation of the son of man but
they try and tell me that it um is the
son of man yeah uh I well whatever they
think the Hat refers to they're going to
tell you well it has pagan origins this
is all blown out of the water let me
tell you what sites to check out okay
yeah here this chck Jack Chick and the
prophet well you have this brother here
it's called Catholic truth Catholic
truth he just did a video on refuting
that it's called The Prophet Catholic
truth right here bam
you go here Catholic truth I'll get you
the link you put
in
Alberto Riviera oh yes I've been seeing
some of this guy watching a bit of this
guy as well Berto let me do Jack check
let me see let me put Catholic
Church Islam because he did a video on
this I
watched do do Catholics and Muslim
worship the one God did the Catholic
Church here did not start Islam but the
Pope come out in 20 2013 and actually
said that we do I don't know if he's
he's reneged on that since no no the
thing is in the statements go watch my
three sessions I did on paragraph 841 of
the catechis Catholic church that says
the Muslims profess to adore the same
God of Abraham and that's based on the
document I always have our time
pronounce this no I just went through it
thoroughly there is a level in which and
I'm not trying to be apologetic for the
Catholic church I'm not apologetic for
anyone but if truth is truth meaning if
there's something wrong Catholic shall
say it I'm not I'm not shy
to not say it this is why when people
are saying oh Sam is upset that CP
criticized the pope what are you hell
talking about man I just did several
sessions criticizing what he said and
other Catholics have been doing the same
thing these guys are delusional but
right here what did he call us
muhammadans
yeah yeah but here's the
thing there is a level this is a and
I've known
this you think I'm gonna remember that I
can't even speak English anyway I'm
gonna give you the link right here
here's the link in private chat here's
the link for rest of you here you see
this is it right here the Catholic
Church did not start Islam notice he's
holding the comic watch he's holding the
comic you'll see the comics so go watch
it the Catholicism started Islam here is
the full video 20 minutes but here's a
snippet he's going to hold up the
comic right here you're going to see the
comic right there there's a comic there
it is you see so it's based these
comments are based on a comic yeah a
comic that was written by Alberto Rivera
who claimed as a Jesuit he was told that
this is how Islam was started now did I
send you the link now here's everyone
else now coming back to the issue there
is a level in which let me explain it's
not that simple it's very complicated so
when you ask me is the of the Quan the
god of Christianity no but notice what I
said is the Allah of the Quran the god
of Christianity absolutely
not God of rabic Judaism the god of
Christianity no the god of rabic Judaism
Orthodox J is not the god of the Bible
but now if you ask me a different
question now watch how compl now guys
you can give shallow answers or you can
try to go deep deeper and deeper by the
Holy Spirit asking him help me to go as
deep as I can to understand the depth of
your wisdom and your beauty and live it
out okay so if I were to ask or if you
ask me the god of the Quran is he the
god of the Bible no but if you ask me is
the god of rabic Judaism the god of the
Bible no but now if you ask me a
different
question the the
Muslims that worship Allah do they
worship the god the Bible I would say
well let's qualify that I can't say yes
or no how many Muslims know who all of
the cran is not
many not many take it I know you're
raising your hand we're going to get to
you next I know you're excited Muslims
call me Allah yeah okay how many Muslims
know who the god of the Quran is not
many now let me ask you another question
how many Christians know who the god of
the Bible
is if I were to go to a Catholic church
or an orthodox church and a Protestant
and I asked them about the Trinity and I
asked them to explain it Father's Holy
Spirit they'll either end up affirming
arianism that Jesus has created
blasphemy or modalism that the father
and son and spirit are the same person
so it's not so easy to say yes or no you
have to say well hold on if you're
telling
me that Muslims know who Allah is
because they know the Quran that's not
true the Great bulk of Muslims are only
Muslims culturally they haven't studied
the Quran they haven't studied Sunnah so
when that Muslim who doesn't know any
better and he cries out to God and he's
told that's the god of Abraham and Isaac
and Jacob the God who sent Jesus The God
Who created heaven the Earth without
beginning then that Muslim has the same
God in mind that you and I
have because if if the Muslim tells you
the God that I cry out to has no
beginning amen he created heaven and
earth yes he's one he's the god of
Abraham Isaac and Jacob He sent Jesus to
be born of the Virgin and Mary's the
greatest of all woman and Jesus is
sinless
so on that
level he has the god that you and I
believe exist No Beginning No End and
the god of Abraham Isaac and Jacob sent
for Jesus you see my
point but now when you go deeper and you
now have a Muslim scholar who
understands Islam and understands that
Christians believe in the Trinity if I
were to ask that muslim okay when you
say Allah you say Allah is a god of
Abraham well the god of Abraham is
father son holy spirit is that your law
they'll say
no you see so it's not yes or no it's
much more nuanced much more deeper much
more complex and if I were to ask
Christians do you know what the Trinity
is most of them won't know so if we're
going to now take it to that level then
great don't worship the god of the Bible
if we I always ask I always ask the
question that you delivered is is Allah
our father Yes and they'll say no but
the average Muslim well if you mean
spiritually metaphorically yes we are
all his sons but then when you tell them
that contradicts the Quan they're
shocked I've had Muslims tell me yeah I
saw an orb too guys I saw a couple orbs
I've had Muslims tell me Well if you
mean God is a spiritual father he's our
father metaphorically yes we are all his
children I said no that contradicts the
crown what do you mean the crown says
God is not a spiritual father and then
when you show them in the Quran then
they get shocked see they don't know the
Quran and it's
Allah Allah's Arabic but I speak syak I
speak syak so you know what I say for
God and
syak Allah is
it yeah but I'm not Muslim not that old
test in Hebrew Moses never heard the
word God was any of the Old Testament
ever written in Aramaic yes parts of it
is Daniel if you go from Daniel chapter
7 I'm sorry Daniel chapter 2 verse4 to
Daniel 7:28 it's all in Aramaic and
their portions of Ezra that's in Aramaic
and there the word for God is Allah
Allah plural so it's Aramaic but my
point is if you were living at time
Moses never heard the word god because
that's English you
speak it's the English word for God
would
say see so this Allah yes Allah of the
Quran is not
God Allah of the Quran is not God and
the Elohim of rebbi Judaism is not God
my God is not the god of rabbiting
Judaism my God is not the L of the Quran
because the ell of the Quran is a false
god the god of forbiding Judaism is not
the god of the Hebrew scriptures and the
god reveal in Jesus Christ but I'm
talking about the religion and their
teaching if I go to their sources it's
not the same God but if I ask the
average Orthodox Jew or Muslim they have
no idea what the religion teaches if I
ask the average Christian you know what
the Trinity is why I'll give you an
example I want to belor point because we
got some other people but my own
Uncle my own Uncle my mother's brother
got into debate with the priest I was
there to watch this
the priest said Jesus Is God he goes no
he's the son of God my uncle will do the
name of the father and of the son of the
Holy Spirit or he'll do it name of the
father and of the son of the Holy Spirit
baptized as an infant in the name of the
father Holy Spirit goes to used to go to
church and take the Eucharist he's
talking to a caldan
priest and the caldan priest caldan
Deacon wasn't a priest it was a caldan
deacon and he was telling the Cal Deacon
Jesus is not God he's a Son of God he
goes no he's God he goes no he's a Son
of
God because to him if Jesus Is God that
means he's his own father are you saying
that Jesus is his own father no that's
what but then that means he's not God
he's a Son of God he had no idea that
Jesus being the Son of God meant he was
God in nature he didn't have that level
of theological
sophistication so do a test for yourself
go to your church this Sunday ask the
parishioners afterwards hey what is the
Trinity ask them to Define it and then
ask them if Jesus Is God then how can he
be the Son of God watch other unun or
they're going to be
motorists unfortunately not blowing
smoke up you mate but um you can't get
you can't get teachings like what you
teach anywhere and I praise God for it I
don't want to make you higher than what
you are I know we talk about that all
the time but um I I've had some really
in-depth conversations with this 7-Day
Adventist and it's really upset the
demons in it and I've been able to stand
firm because of the teachings that
you've delivered over the last 12 months
praise God well you've been going a lot
longer than that but that's how long
I've been learn stuff you learn the
stuff and go teach it in your Parish
help others yeah teach yeah now thank
you very much Sam for for what you're
doing for God and praise God for you
mate praise God for you guys love the
Lord
awesome love your work thank you Amen
brother